this week on generation next we're going
to be talking about all the biggest news
from gamescom but we're also going to be
comparing gamescom 2013
to gamescom 2020 and per your request
we're going to be talking to our text
per to see what you should be looking
out for if you're buying a new tv or
monitor for playstation 5 or xbox series
x
or both
hello everyone and welcome once again to
generation next gamespot's weekly show
all about the ps5 and xbox series x
i'm joined by xbox expert jordan remay
yo
and playstation pro tomorrow hussein
absolutely
writhing with anticipation for new
consoles
let's
all right so like i said up front this
week uh
all about gamescom but before we delve
into that
uh quickly gonna go to tam with
playstation
pre-order reservations yeah it's getting
wild and wacky in the world of
playstation because sony
hasn't told us when the playstation 5 is
coming out it's not told us
how much it's going to cost but it has
given the opportunity
for a select few who will be chosen
based on
weird criteria to be the first to get an
opportunity
to buy one so what does that mean
they've effectively started a lottery
and on the official playstation 5
website or the official playstation.com
website
they're inviting people to register for
the chance to be the first
to pre-order a ps5 console so it's
limited quantities
um will be available and they're
inviting existing
consumers to be the first to pre-order
and if you click down into like the faq
there's a few more details in there and
it sounds like what they're doing is
they're
basing who they invite on interest and
people have taken that to mean oh it's
got to be people who have loads of
trophies or many hours in a video game
it's completely unclear all you have to
do is put in your playstation id
so i imagine they're kind of grabbing
the information from your id
and basing whether they invite you or
not on that
um but yeah if you're super eager to
play
you know uh in the launch window
or as we got in the latest gamescom um
presentation ratchet and clank which is
now going to be available in the launch
window whenever that is and you you
don't want to risk
waiting for it on day one you can take a
shot at getting
yourself in this lottery and maybe
getting a chance to
pre-order one it's a lot of hoops to
jump through for the chance to get
something but
that's what they're doing who's the
willy wonka of playstation
because this feels very in the chocolate
factory
it's gotta be shoot here you see though
it's gotta be shoe hey you should
alright
i mean i wonder what i mean what is your
golden ticket how many platinums you
have
i mean i've got four i don't have enough
i've got i've got one and i feel like
that's not more powerful we all know
what it is
yeah i feel like that's a more powerful
statement than people who are like i've
got 50. i've got one
teammates friends to hell with that
but let's use this as a segue like you
said we don't know
when it's coming up how much it's gonna
cost and we just had gamescom opening
night live
uh the jeffs because if uh the game
awards are the kilis these are the jeffs
and i went back and looked at gamescom
2013 so
just before a couple months before the
ps4 and xbox one came out
look at what we knew about those
consoles at gamescom 2013. so
in terms of playstation we knew uh
the release date november 15th a couple
weeks later in europe and other
territories
uh that sony promised 33 games before
december 31st but we didn't know the
exact launch lineup
um they'd clarified that ps3 to ps4
upgrades would be significantly
discounted
color options for dual shock and uh
price cuts on a vita and a 199.12
gigabyte ps3 model
xbox had revere revealed its entire
launch lineup 23 games where they didn't
have
a uh launch date but they did announce
that a few days after gamescom was
finished
they showed off the xbox one dashboard
which i guess we kind of do have with
the series x
there was obviously hands-on with both
consoles uh and they also unveiled id
at xbox and jordan i'm going to come to
you first
was this gamescom very gamescomie it
didn't feel like a next
game it's weird to think that at least
for
series x we know that it's coming in
november which is
what two months away three months away
and
it's like nothing for series x and like
we got to see 12 minutes which looks
like a cool game they have a lot of star
talent like going to that which was
super surprising but like there was
nothing at gamescom that just like drew
my attention i was like
you want to buy this game and the best
way to play this game is on
xbox series x which is coming out in
whatever day on this game i mean there
was that there was a game pass trailer
again reaffirming the best deal in
gaming but like at the same time
i
i didn't see anything on the xbox side
that was like very
next-gen it's so strange like
tam what do you think from a
playstation's because playstation
gamescom 2013 they went all out
yeah i think from a broadly speaking for
both playstation and microsoft the
tricky thing right now
is the state of the world that we live
in right so you imagine that's got to
play a huge
factor because of covert manufacturing
delivery that kind of stuff
there's probably a a mindset let's wait
until the
absolute latest we can do for
playstation specifically
i think there was more of a cause and a
reason or impetus to
give out as much information as early as
possible in 2013
because if you think back um playstation
was coming off
you know being on the back foot because
of playstation 3 and they had just
scored a major win
the pr kind of cycle the marketing um
momentum was in their
favor after the reveal the playstation
had earned a lot of mind share
positive mindshare because of the you
know no sharing no always online whereas
microsoft had kind of fumbled the launch
or the
reveal kind of fumbled very easy oh man
they were like
me trying to play uh football as a
goalkeeper back in my teenage years
letting every goal in um but like
um so they had the momentum and it felt
like a good time to strike and keep on
striking so they were on the offense the
entire year
so outside of e3 the next major beat was
gamescom and given the momentum they
built up it made perfect sense for to
give everyone the information
that they you know that would guarantee
their purchasing purchasing decision
hot off their success and hot off
microsoft stumble
so that's why they had that now they're
kind of more in a
closer to market leader position where
they don't have as much reason to do
that
they can effectively ride the momentum
of the playstation 4 success and
take a more casual approach to it which
isn't necessarily the best idea or the
most consumer-friendly idea
and it could still potentially fire you
know backfire in their face if they're
not careful
because microsoft is doing a lot with
you know game pass and
saying that they've got the most
powerful console whereas sony seems to
be taking a bit more chill
it'll probably be fine but i think
that's a big reason why we don't have as
much meat on our
on the playstation 5 bones right now um
but i would i think everyone is kind of
reaching the end of their tether with
this kind of
holding their cards too close to their
chest for both sides
it does make you wonder
if stuff isn't going on behind the
scenes and something might slip and it's
just a game of chicken to see who's
gonna go
first that would be like obviously worst
case scenario obviously there are
way bigger things to think about that's
going on in the world right now
but it feels weird i mean 2020 has just
been a weird year all around but in
terms of a new console launch it doesn't
feel like it yeah i don't think anything
at least for sony's situation i don't
know if if anything will slip given that
they put up this pre-order page
to put it up and then um delay it would
be
a bit of a pr nightmare for them but
then at the same time they could say oh
we've got a bunch of people who are
guaranteed to get it whenever it does
come out we're going to open it up more
widely so you can order directly from us
we're going to select more people but
i'd be very surprised if
that console slips same for microsoft
yeah me i mean i'm just saying i'm just
you know forever a slight pessimist
just in case you know you know set your
expectations slightly lower you're never
disappointed so that was all the big
news
from gamescom hopefully we get answers
to some of those questions but
while we wait it's time to talk to our
textbook
about what monitors and tvs you should
be looking out for if you wanted to
upgrade before next year
yeah that's right we still don't know
when the new consoles are coming out
unless they announce it while we're
recording this which after what happened
with call of duty last week wouldn't put
it past sony and microsoft
for context we don't know anything like
i assume there's a new card this year
they are teasing the crap out of stuff
sending people packages we're recording
this before anything has been announced
meanwhile
but anyway the least we can do while
we're getting excited for new consoles
is to prepare how we're going to enjoy
them that's right
upgrade monitors and tvs and honestly
you guys have been asking for this
that's right we do read the comments um
so you've asked and we're gonna answer
and when i say we're gonna answer what i
mean is actually we've brought in
someone way more qualified uh game
sports resident texbert
michael heim hi uh damn texpert is
that's um
that's some big shoes to fill i know
that was my initial role when it came to
game spot but
i do like to keep up with tech a little
bit because you know uh it's still
still interesting still fascinating
always evolving uh but yeah
i'm excited to join y'all because i miss
i miss doing things with
my friends lucy and tam but it's it's
good to be here on generation next
oh we miss you too bud this year has
been so weird remember the office
damn it's good tv show that's for the uk
wow
well well well how the turntables
all right let's like get into the meat
of it michael let's say i'm in the
market for brand new tv
to enjoy my ps5 or series x on
what should i be looking for what are
the the like the bullet points
my checklist as i'm going into well
perusing best buy's website or something
sure yes uh the basics is that uh 4k
obviously i think that nowadays the 4k
is the standard so
any basic tv that you're gonna find uh
on sale or whatever uh on best buy
that's gonna be like
uh like featured tvs that you're gonna
get they're all going to be 4k
i think this was more the case a couple
years back but it was
uh there were some tvs that were 4k
non-hdr
but i think hdr is a very important
feature to have on your tv
because games will be taking advantage
of it more and more
as we go into the next generation now
hdm hdr
if you're not familiar is that uh it
widens the color gamut so
the the dark parts of your screen will
look extra rich
the colors will look extra rich the
difference between
white and black in the in the color
scheme is going to look a lot more
realistic
so that's fairly standard now but just
double check to make sure that if you're
buying
a 4k tv especially if you're you're
going budget level especially budget
level
just double check to make sure that that
tv has hdr
as well there are also different specs
to hdr but i think that
at the low price range as long as it has
it you'll get
some sort of advantage visually when you
plug in your new console whatever and
take advantage of that feature
so another thing that you should
probably be aware of
that isn't necessarily advertised
straight up when you look
at tv specs is latency
and that's obviously important because
you don't want to you know
have your inputs be lagging behind
when you're actually trying to do them
most tvs are fine with that but
there's when you go cheaper the latency
tends to be
kind of or it can be bad uh sometimes
there's ghosting but just do that little
extra step
and if you're eyeing us if you're eyeing
a particular model
of a tv just do a little extra research
and look into
what the response time and what the
latency is
i think around 20 25 milliseconds is
fine
uh but anything higher than that you may
want to think twice about it
michael i need you to talk dirty to me
tell me about refresh rates oh refresh
rates yeah
uh so if you're looking at a tv and
you're spending a lot more
you definitely want to at least get
something that's 120 hertz
uh refresh rate what this means is that
the tv can display up to 120 fps
now why that matters now is because ps5
and xbox series x
are kind of flexing in the in the fact
that they can
do 4k 128 hertz that obviously depends
on the content
not very few things are going to be able
to take advantage of that
that's obviously on the higher end so if
you are going to spend a little bit more
definitely make sure you got that as
well so we talked about what to look for
what should i be uh what i want to avoid
sure yeah in terms of when you go
higher in price range i think that you
should
you should probably avoid led displays
not that they're bad
but if you're spending upwards of a
thousand dollars you definitely want to
get an
oled display oled displays show
much richer colors the picture quality
is much better than leds
uh or led displays so but they do tend
to be more expensive so
again if you're in that price range of a
thousand fifteen hundred
uh definitely look into some good uh
oled displays
there's also things like once you go
into the higher range you want to make
sure that
uh has or any tv actually has like a
good
game mode uh which kind of cuts down on
post processing in the tv
and then allows your tv to actually be
more responsive so look into the options
there
and see how that affects uh your your
tv experience or how that would affect
your tv experience
and another thing too is when you get
into the higher uh refresh rate stuff if
you are going to get 120 hertz display
make sure it has variable refresh rate
uh integrated in it because the consoles
the series x and the ps5 are also gonna
have free sync
which means if the frames drop you won't
experience screen tearing
and that's uh it's a really nice feature
to have i don't know to what extent
obviously because it depends on how
these games are going to perform if
they're going to take advantage of those
high frame rates
but if they do you want to make sure
that you at least have that feature in
that tv that you invest in
but what let's say that i'm going i'm
going rogue
and i don't want a tv and i want a
monitor
uh well you know monitors are also
there's a whole lot of options there i'm
actually more familiar with them because
uh i am a pc gamer uh but if you are
going to use uh your
your console for uh at a desktop i guess
and use a monitor
i think the main thing that you need to
keep in mind is that most
budget friendly monitors are not hdr
so you may find a like a good 4k monitor
good size
4k monitor uh it's a decent price but
chances are
it won't have hdr and i think that's
that's really important for
console games because that's going to
become or is
pretty standard uh even with the xbox
one x
and the ps4 pro uh hdr is kind of like
this wild thing that some people say is
even more effective than
the jump from 1080p to 4k of course it
depends on who you ask
but if you again if you're gonna invest
in a new display for your consoles
you need hdr and that's a little bit
harder to come by in
computer monitors but also i think that
response time is also really important
for for pc gaming
i think it's it's less of an issue with
monitors as it is with tvs because
uh monitors are meant for the desktop pc
experience and
pc games can go up to 144hz
240 hertz depending on your specs uh so
that's something to keep in mind but i
don't think that you need to necessarily
um it's not going to be hard to find
something that takes advantage of that
so you'll be able to find a 4k 120 hertz
monitor if you want to go that route but
expect to spend a lot of money if you
also want to get hdr
if jeff bezos rolls up and is like you
need to get this hdmi cable that's 50
and is plated in gold should i believe
him or should i just get the 10
one is there any difference between a
high-end and low-end
price-wise hdmi cable if if jeff bezos
roll up man his hands it's on site with
him yeah
but if he's trying to sell you a if he's
trying to sell you an hdmi cable
uh you know the anyone
any old hdmi cable should work fine the
one thing i will say that you need to
keep in mind is that
if you are going up to 4k and you have
a 120 hertz display or television
you want to get an hdmi 2.1 cable to
make sure that you can take advantage of
that so that's the new hdmi spec
i think that if i recall correctly basic
hdmi cables like
2.0 b can do 4k 60
but i don't think they can do 4k 120
hertz
and that's why you want to make sure
that you have an hdmi 2.1
cable so you can take advantage of that
when the opportunity arises but again
like those are
going to be fairly rare cases at least
in the in the near future but
you know if you're going to spend the
money make sure you're prepared
bonus tip get a sound bar oh
that's another thing too is like don't
rely on tv speakers tv speakers
are never good they might be okay but if
you're you know if you're playing an
xbox series x or ps5 game and you're
relying on tv speakers you are missing
out on half the experience
sound bars are really cheap now and i've
only just got on one for the first time
and i'm impressed at how good they are
they're relatively cheap as well so like
my one not well not that way sponsored
anyway is a vizio and it's real good
tom and i have the exact same tv and uh
sound bar stuff
definitely vouch for that yeah
that's that's that's a pro tip right
there all right well michael thank you
so much
for joining us and teaching us teaching
us scrubs about monitors and tvs because
honestly i just kind of go and look at
what's on sale but now i actually know
what to look out for
um thank you again and we'll see you
next time
of course thank you for having me thank
you
uh jordan tam for joining me and michael
of course to talk about next gen we'll
be back again
next friday uh time in the meantime
where can people find you
you'll find me on a retailer searching
for a new tv
even though i really don't need one but
you know if you're going to spend money
and
to spend all of it and be impoverished
and i'm on twitter
i'm on twitter hit me up for bad tweets
jordan what about you you can find me on
twitter at jm remay
desperately trying to figure out what
events we have left to announce a
release date for silk song
oh one day man it'll come it'll come
and i'm on twitter at lucy james games
posting pictures of my forearm because i
got really excited about the dragon age
teaser
oh that was your forearm it just looked
like a ring i think it was
it just looked like a really white beam
of light
all right we'll see you next week
[Music]
you